Keith Pompeii these 76ers beat writer
for the philadelphia inquirer he had a
great seat for that Keith thanks for
joining us what did you what did you
come away with thinking last night just
may not be as good as everyone everyone
thought they were you know the last
month of the season
the Sixers what they ended the season
with 16 consecutive victories but when
you look at the schedule you know the
teams were okay but it was the easiest
schedule in the NBA for that during that
portion of time and then right now they
go into Boston and they lose to
undermanned squad twice and they
basically lost the same way that they've
been losing you know for the first five
months of the season four months of the
season but they surrendered early they
settled for three-pointers you know even
when they would have been better suited
feeding a post within B and you know Ben
Simmons just didn't come to play this
time now that's I'm not going to say you
know I must say that that's like
aberration of him because he typically
comes to play but it just seemed like
you know it looked like the Sixers from
January and in December and November
they just didn't look like this team
that was that won 16 games in a row last
night I wondered this with all this
momentum you know Philadelphia you know
city of Champions and then everybody was
all in on the 76ers and then I thought
man are they are they ready for this
moment granted it's a wounded Boston
team you're taking on and if you get out
of that round we're not sure who you're
facing but it felt like everybody had
seen enough you know that they took a
shot from Miami they rebounded and came
back and ended up you know blowing him
out but our the expectation level isn't
too high in Philadelphia for the 76ers a
lot of people got caught up and then
right now I think when they played Miami
everyone thought it was going to be easy
you know because you know you're saying
okay Ben Simmons never played in a
playoff series before but wow he was
calm he was relaxed so everyone thought
that the Sixers are too team the beat in
the East
and me personally this is their real
playoff test and what I mean by that is
it's like you know Miami you know you
know God loved them the heat and
everything like that but I just felt
like that this team and and uh in
fueling Boston is more of a contender so
when you go on the road in Boston that's
a true playoff type atmosphere you know
and that's when you learn about your
guys you learn that who can play and
who's young and it just seems like you
know the playoff inexperience just
showed especially in the last game so
yes you know I think that you know we
did put a lot of high expectations on
this team but it was kind of like they
got a little bit of Fool's Gold now I'm
not going to say that they can't come
back and win this series they're gonna
be tough but the Sixers just aren't you
know living up to the hype that
everybody was given on the last month of
the season finish this sentence
if the 76ers don't advance what I think
the 76ers don't advance everyone's gonna
say it's still a great season okay cuz
when you think about it they won 52
games you know they ended the regular
season with a 16 game winning streak you
know no one expected this team that
could go that far so when you look at it
you know they're still trending in the
right direction so I don't think that
even if they lose this series I don't
think that you can say that this season
was a failure let's face it two years
ago 2 Sixers were 10 and 72 right now
they're in the second round of the
playoffs now I'm just fascinated with
the Ben Simmons thing that you know
people say oh you're being too hard on
him he's a rookie
well Jason Tatum last I look is still a
rookie right so let's let's let's get
that out and you know let and he's a
real rookie you know Ben has at least
been in the environment of playing in
the NBA not in postseason or at least
being around it but I what what forced
him out of his game so early and he
never got back into that rhythm I mean
you said it was mental he said he was
trying to think about doing too much
it could also be the physicality you
know I think that you know the
difference between Boston and Miami you
know Miami had a couple guys who were
physical but you know they also were
doing some dirty things to the 76ers but
I think that in Miami guy excuse me the
Boston guys is like more way of life
like you know I covered Marcus Morris
when he was in high school and he always
came to me across the media's like a
tough you know blue-collar type of guy
you know you you look at Marcus smart a
tough blue-collar type of guy the same
thing with Terry Rozier you know and
then there's something else that you
have to factor in so you look at Al
Horford you know who power forward
Center but we all look at him as like an
athletic type of guy you know we talked
about his athleticism well right now Ben
Simmons is going up against bigs who
needs a little bit more athletic than
them it's not like you know the big
disparity as it would be in the past you
not I mean so I think that Boston is
just a bad matchup ground key thanks for
joining us certainly a lot on the line
tomorrow night in Philadelphia we
appreciate your time thanks for having
me
Keith Pompey's the beat writer for the
philadelphia inquirer
has a game three tomorrow night in
Philadelphia for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]